May it be the era of Kings and Queens, or
may it be today’s modern world….
Silk has always been the choice of several
people for all the wonderful qualities
it has!
Since ancient times, textile industry has
been ruled by silk!
However, being in demand does NOT mean it
is easily available and is
economically viable!
Yes, it’s not easily available, and is expensive!
This has made people search for alternatives!
And finally the search was
concluded when an artificial fibre resembling
silk was synthesised.
Wait a second…Does that mean we find synthetic
fibre which is like silk?
Of
course yes!
And what do we call it?
It is known as RAYON!
Have we come across this fibre?
Of course yes!
It has got several daily life
applications.
From the fabric we use to make various outfits,
to the bed sheets
used by us… it is used in many applications!
But if we say that it is synthetic and at
the same time has appearance of silk,
then how exactly is it made?
Let us know this first.
It was in the end of nineteenth century that
silk availability was a concern due
to its extremely high cost.
As a result many chemists began finding an
alternative to it.
Finally after many successful attempts to
make something close to silk, a type
of rayon got introduced in France.
In around 1889 a French industrialist named
Hilaire de Chardonnet introduced the “CHARDONNET
SILK” which was the first
ever man made rayon manufactured at industrial
scale.
Since then many varieties have got introduced
that have the appearance of silk
but are actually Rayon!
But how do we exactly make such a beautiful
fibre?
The commencing material
is CELLULOSE.
Wait a second….cellulose is what we find
in plants right?
Yes!
Usually wooden pulp is used as a source of
cellulose.
This is converted
into soluble compound that is further pressed
with force through an
instrument having fine holes.
What will be the result of this?
Yes!
Thin fibres
will be formed.
These are further treated with chemicals and
at the end, rayon
fibres are obtained.
Now you may wonder that even if we process
it, the starting material still
remains natural!
The starting material I’m talking about
is cellulose.
So how
can we say that it is synthetic?
You are on the correct track!
This is exactly why
Rayon is not considered to be entirely synthetic!
In fact Rayon is known to be
Semi-synthetic.
That is partly natural and partly synthetic!
Now we have been talking about this ARTIFICIAL
SILK for quite some time.
Can
you tell me where exactly we use it?
The major use of Rayon is in making clothes!
Yes!
Rayon can be blended with
many dyes to get vibrant shades, which is
why it is widely used in the textile
industry.
Not only clothing, but it can also be used
in making bed sheets when mixed
with natural fibres like Cotton.
Can we mix it with any other natural fibre
as well?
Yes!
Rayon can also be
blended with wool.
This helps us get soft, shiny fibre that can
be used to make
carpets!
Now you may be wondering if we can use rayon
to make some tough material
that has great strength…
Well, tensile strength is not the property
of Rayon.
In
fact it is best exhibited by the fibre Nylon.
But to study it, you will have to
watch our next video!